boom alrighty we are there again by
default five-minute standard unrated if
you'd like something different Fisher
random or a faster time controller or a
combination of the two feel free if
you're playing make sure to mute that
stream nobody wants to be a listener of
the stream because I throw out sneaky
duds sneaky duds that you might bite you
might bite at the sneaky duds okay what
does that mean what just happened there
I have a bit more control over the
center do I just played e5 or right away
if push could throw my night here there
could then follow another push and I
could be having some structural issues
just going to go with this establish
upon in the center paved the way for my
dark square Bishop could be a little bit
annoying I could be a little bit more
annoying to White's Queen side as soon
as this capture occurs I could view it
as controlling the center a bit more and
i could put direct pressure on the heart
of this structure be too however i think
there's a convenient response rook here
the bishop could drop back let's do it
anyhow let us do that anyhow I think
Bishop b3 is not a good choice why not
why would that not be a good choice
Bishop a 6 that's the no soup for you
move No castling for you move Bishop c5
or Bishop e7 Bishop c5 would say you're
going to have to work a little bit
harder to get this F for advanced in and
well maybe I want to make my opponent
work
harder work a little harder Castle next
and eventually well how do you complete
the queenside development could be quite
annoying keep in mind the strength of
bishops that function on the jacent
diagonals if white wants to complete
development by Bishop back and then
bringing this guy out Bishop a6 I think
could be quite annoying let me castle so
f for how do you follow up f4 mmm me
just d6 okay apparently this is getting
ready to be played be four I just go a
five before i could play Bishop here let
me just got a five that's more of a I
don't know if its best but I think it's
a good practical choice just immediately
kind of thrilling my part up there and
preventing probably the one thing that
light was intending on doing should I
have any fear of pins actually one thing
that I think is a bit annoying is maybe
I'm never threatening to take this pond
if should the bishop move because of
night a for with the fork so that has me
slightly worried I wonder however about
bishop d no no no no no wait a second
all right no yeah I'm thinking about
this still why did I just make that
sound no no no no I'm thinking okay so
as soon as the Queen left control over
d5 I could get this in d5 right now d5
take stakes if Queen takes pawn cheese
on my bishop and rook but I have Bishop
2d6 hitting the Queen and then I could
take the bishop follow that d5 i think i
could get in take stakes I'm on it
enough it's it again I could be
defending again if I'm in a pin I'm
gonna go forward with them it's very
forcing oh also another thing is I could
develop with tempo Bishop g4 and maybe
provoke this let me recap sure I should
have been in print
meld with that Bishop g4 if something
like this is played then the king is in
stalemate okay so what am I missing oh
man that's what I'm missing I'm gonna be
dropping stuff is that what's happening
no no no what Cal k so I should have
considered this but I have I have a good
reply Bishop here Bishop here or bishop
here defends against the rookie and the
night is there anyone that is better is
there something more forceful that might
there be back rank issues for white hmm
Bishop right here it seems a bit more
cozy to go there um yeah pretty sure
I'll be able to get out of this pin I
just wanna wondering do I go here where
do I go let's just go here everything is
defended think my opponent was seeing
that they could eventually get get at my
night but unfortunately um okay well
unprotected pieces leads to tactics
right sometimes pins and stuff like that
but they can also help you get out of
tactics so if my opponent thinks there's
some tactic in that of this pin I have
the ability to get out of that with a
similar tactic of exploiting the Queen's
I protected Nature on e5 so if brooke
here i could have been playing Queen c7
or f6 and if captured I could be
retreating the knight and my piece is
saved I can grab this pond but maybe I
just want to be in a position where I
could do what or I could do what let me
just attack that Queen
I gotta play quicker Bishop here i'm
pointing now right at h 2 h 2 so if i'm
able to play Queen h4 I can maybe attack
the bishop or the pond there might be
some combination of taking here and then
playing clean age 4 or queen h4 first I
think white needs to play something like
Queen age 5 to prevent my clean from
coming out here I could maybe still be
kicking the Queen around a little bit
with g6 okay she's not playing there so
I think that my opponent is my opponent
wanted oh I could have just taken the
Queen they mouth slip that they wanted
to take back immediately and that's what
they got that's what they got they got
to take back so where did she really
mean to go she meant to go here to offer
a queen exchange that's my favorite and
I'm up a piece so I'm going to go
forward with it I have to be a bit
careful i was thinking about rook here
to attack the bishop however after
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes rook
here I'm I'm in some trouble so how do
you get out of this you retreat the
night create some tension between the
bishops and well I'm up of heat now well
okay I'm up a minor piece my opponent
does have two pawns for i still have
pressure on the heart now I'm hitting
the bishop in this pond and things are
much much more smoother here if the
bishop has to go back home it is a sad
situation so what do you do okay that's
upon that should be taken keep in mind
the strength of being able to take out
that middle pawn of a group of three
these guys now become weak and you could
target them so these are just I believe
going to fall one by one this pond is
pinned just I have to make certain of a
flight square if I'm going to go with
the flight square i'm going to do that i
don't have to do that right now but i'm
going to create a dark colored
flight square dark-colored flight square
off of this guy stay away from the dark
squares if your opponent has one Bishop
remaining and it's not a dark square so
you do it's not best but I'm just going
to make sure there's no trickiness avoid
the trickiness I think rook a 2 is
probably best there's no rush slight
improvements time is probably the only
issue if at all 43 seconds is still
quite a bit he is very good ok now this
rook is being hit this is going to be up
a full rock soon full rook and
soon-to-be mate assume to be me this
pond is also ready to score ready to
score all right we have reservation good
game lagoo let me back up flip what were
the things that caught my eye one thing
out of this veteran akov don't take do
not take on c6 I don't think it's a good
choice to help build the center and
allow me to put pressure on this B to
Point instead Knight c3 e5 Knight be
Knight d2 b 5 and we continue in theory
for sometimes so it's worth
investigating that line but I would not
consider night takes c6 as my first
choice this I think is fine well this
pond maybe maybe immediately go forward
with this I think where the tables
really shifted and I saw in advantages
when I was able to play d5 with tempo
even if you don't end up going in for
that the sequence of moves maybe you're
thinking you could get a pot or the
piece back I do not believe that that is
the case so instead of making the Queen
move still keep a close eye on this pond
consider maybe what
maybe what you could consider just as
they're saying in the game you could
still bring the bishop out and have
available to you night a for should I
take on v2 so I think from here instead
of Queen to d2 even right now hang on
instead of a 3 i'm not sure that that's
really a good one to go forward with am
I really are you really threatening
before is that something I should worry
about I think you run your run the risk
of just putting this night and into into
an uncomfortable state and in a pin so
maybe do without a 3 B 4 idea instead
consider f4 and well no actually I'm
seeing another reason for a 3 let me
retract this this a 3 idea like if you
bring the bishop out now rook takes pawn
Knight a for you would have our I would
have ripped to be for hitting the bishop
so a three at least takes away that be
four square and it allows the bishop to
move so maybe it's okay but here queen e
to F for Bishop out are the other ones I
think you should be considering d5 I
have a center and this is just not a
good capture to go forward with at first
I thought it was could work out in your
favor because of how active your queen
was after she captures on e5 hitting the
rook and having lateral movement at all
along that fifth rank but it's just not
really working out so it's a dead game
at that point okay good game Lagoo let
me let me get out of this game